and our next speaker
has a
golden doodle puppy
but a puppy itself is interesting
but he is teaching his puppy named
pickles to speak
using a sound board
and augmentative alternative
communication
so i'm sure we have lots to learn about
that
or his talk we'll probably learn about
both
so please
everyone give a nice warm welcome to
madhava
hello everyone welcome to my talk remote
data science pets unleashed
my name is matava i'm an engineering
team leader open mind i work
predominantly on sifting grid and i'm
coming to you from sunny brisbane
australia
in this talk i'd like to discuss
motivations for remote data science meet
two pets dp and snpc
you'll get to see sifting grid in action
later we'll discover our private ai
series and finally you'll get to hear a
bit about what makes openmind unique
but i'd like to start with a key premise
we believe that our ability to answer
important questions is limited because
we can't access existing data
existing data in another country
existing data in another organization or
even in another department
and the solutions to many of mankind's
most challenging problems exist but
simply that the the access to train the
models the access to the data necessary
to train those models does not
and there are many problems like this
but i'd like to drill into two
specifically today the first one is
breast cancer
sadly one in eight women will contract
breast cancer in their lifetime
and tragically over 700 000 women a year
die of breast cancer
one of the reasons why this number is so
high is that if you today went into a
hospital to get a mammography
the radiologist might look at it and
they might give you a negative result
but there's a one in four chance in some
places that you would get a false
negative which would mean that you would
actually have cancer you would go on to
live your life for several years only to
discover later and your treatment
options would be greatly reduced
now this seems like the perfect problem
that we could just throw a deep learning
model out right a classifier and solve
it um unfortunately in 2021 there's been
a paper that's shown that um 38
different ai breast cancer models out of
those 36 performed worse than a
radiologist the remaining two were worse
than two radiologists
so you know it's our belief that uh this
the reason why these models are so poor
is because they probably weren't trained
on enough data now if we've learned
anything from the latest
state-of-the-art results over the last
few years that particularly for
challenging problems
you know three million images which is
what the estimate of the current largest
data set available is is simply not
enough images
despite this
we can estimate that over the last 10
years we've probably had about 8 billion
images collected
so you know the the
data exists to train this model um but
we're only using a small fraction of it
and hence we're getting subhuman results
and so i wanted to hammer back this
point that you know solutions like deep
learning models they exist but the
access to train on the private data
necessary uh to solve these problems it
does not um and there's another example
i'd like to show and that is uh global
trade so currently the united nations
has started a new pilot program where
they're experimenting with some of the
pet technologies that we'll be
discussing in this talk called the un
pet lab
what they're looking at is the sort of
import and export trade data that
crosses borders between their member
nations now in this case you can see
that things normally match
every now and then though things just
disappear you know on the left here we
have 3.6 million dollars worth of straw
but on the american side we're receiving
200 000 i mean that's a huge difference
this is a global problem
up to five different member nations are
getting together to try to solve this
problem
all without having to share each other's
highly valuable and secret trade data
and so you can imagine in this case the
solution which is simple arithmetic
already exists but the access to this
private data does not
and so you might be thinking well why
don't we just put it all in a big
database you know why can't we take 8
billion images and train put it all in
one database and train the world's best
breast cancer model well why can't we
just put all of the world's private
trade information into one database to
answer this question
there are a lot of reasons why we
wouldn't want to do this but i'd like to
focus on one in particular today and
that is that it's simply not convenient
so imagine i wanted to solve this breast
cancer problem what i would do is i
would need to go out and collect more
data than anyone ever has before right
so let's see what that would look like
well i'm gonna have to contact the first
hospital or get on the phone with their
legal department you know and i'll have
a lot of conversations backwards and
forwards and you know our lawyers are
now going to have to negotiate and this
takes a really long time
um eventually they're going to be asking
us like where are you going to put that
data you know how are you going to
manage the risk and ultimately we may
need to do some kind of background
checks for our staff and you know this
really just doesn't scale uh imagine we
completed this exercise and now we need
to rinse and repeat this with slight
variations hundreds or even a thousand
times
this problem is intractable it hasn't
been done despite the money and the
willpower
and so if you think about it actually
you know before the internet existed we
had this same problem with public data
if i wanted to book a flight you know i
would just be able to go online and do
it i'd have to pick up the phone and
talk to someone you know if i wanted to
find out whether a shop was open i
couldn't just google it i'd need to pick
up the phone and call them and if they
didn't answer i just wouldn't know the
answer
and so what we kind of need here is the
same self-service model that the
internet has provided for public data
but for private data so that data owners
don't need to be on the phone you know
sitting standing by waiting for your
call 24 hours a day you know or
answering lots and lots of emails to do
with uh legal negotiations and contracts
um just so that uh data data scientists
who want to study the world's you know
private data to solve the world's most
challenging problems so they don't also
need to have uh legal agreements and
contracts with hundreds or thousands of
different organizations so you know
the thing we're talking about here is
kind of called remote data science and
i'd like to drill in a little bit and
show you sort of how it would look
so imagine you have you know your sort
of organization with your private data
you upload that into a server we'll call
this a domain right and then you have
your external data scientist and they
are you know sort of interacting
externally uh over the network with this
server now they're able to ask uh
questions and answer you know the
questions they have for problems by your
api without having to copy any of the
data
they wouldn't just be interacting with a
single organization they would be on a
sort of like federated network of global
private data
now you might be saying well we have an
internet and we have servers why can't i
just take my data put it into a server
create an api give a username and
password and be done with it well
unfortunately there's this problem
called adversarial attacks so i want to
give you an example here of how this
looks imagine we have a table of data
containing the code positive results for
a bunch of people right this is uh
private health information we need to
protect it but we also want to allow
data scientists to be able to study it
right in aggregate and get some
population statistics so imagine we have
this api and they can say like okay how
many people have covered right in this
case we've got 11 that's 11 out of 20
gives a 55 answer right but what if we
have a data scientist who's you know a
little bit naughty a little bit
nefarious and they want to learn
something about one of our subjects if
they were able to perturbate the query
in such a way that they could exclude a
particular subject from the data set in
the query then they might be able to
learn something about that subject so
imagine in this hypothetical query
language we have they could do something
sort of like you know names greater than
or equal to b star if they're able to do
something like this they could exclude
someone like andrew from this data set
so in this case we're going to have you
know 10 out of 20
of 19. so the result has gone down
now if we step back and think about this
um if we're able to to perform a query
um that's not modified we potentially
don't know anything about this subject
that we're trying to uncover
however if we were able to exclude them
from the from the query and compare the
results if that person had a positive
result and they were removed there would
be less of them and so we could infer
that the number if it went down that
they did in fact have coded and
conversely if the number went up we
could infer that possibly they they
didn't right so you know what's the
solution to this problem anyone
pets
let's meet our first pet we've got
laplace the differentially private puppy
and i want to talk to you about
differential privacy so
imagine you know i ask you to flip a
coin
if it comes up heads i want you to just
tell the truth so in this case if you
have coded and the result is is true
then you say yes and if not you say no
um and it you know flip the coin and if
you get tails what i want you to do is
you're going to have to flip it a second
time
so on this second flip if it comes up
heads this time you're going to answer
true positive yes i have covered
irrespective of whether you do and if it
comes up tails you're going to have to
answer no right and this could be a lie
but it sort of depends on what your
original answer is
now what this results is
that you know if you look at the ground
truths and the answers that are given at
any given
output if you were to uncover what an
individual's answer was
there'd be just as likely a chance that
they were lying
so what this does is it gives us some
interesting properties right so one of
our goals here is to ensure that
statistical analysis doesn't compromise
privacy
um you know output should appear
identical with or without a given row so
if we remove andrew it should look
essentially the same
and we want to give our data subjects a
concept of plausible deniability so they
can always say well you know i was lying
even if you figured out what their
answer was right and to make this sort
of work across large amounts of
different types of data we need to be
able to tune the amount of noise that
we're adding so we can adjust for a sort
of privacy budget um and and most
importantly you know um this noise that
we're adding we're in control of it and
we know how much it is so we can just
remove it leaving the signal allowing us
to train models and do any kind of
regular machine learning so you know you
can think of this it sort of works on
you know mathematical operations and
functions or database queries and and
finally there's this concept we have of
a so-called accountant and what that
does is allows us to internally track
the the privacy of individual data
subjects between queries and even
between data sets
so there's a problem here though you
might have realized earlier i was saying
like don't centralize all your data and
there it is that's a central data set
right so what can we do about this i
mean we could we could split it up and
decentralize it but then like how do we
query it like that doesn't make any
sense right that's ridiculous so does
anyone know what the solution is
pets all right let's meet our second pet
we've got beaver the spc cat snpc stands
for secure multi-party compute
so imagine that andrew has the number
five and he wants to have somebody else
multiply it by two and give him back the
correct answer without ever revealing
the original number that sounds like a
riddle it doesn't sound possible right
but it is so what we're going to do is
going to take that original number and
split it into two secret shares that
when you combine back together equal the
original number we're then going to get
two friends we've got critical and
george i'm going to say to them okay
we're going to give you a secret share
each hold on to it and don't share it
with anyone
we're then going to so at this point
essentially we've uh achieved encryption
right neither party knows the original
value and they can't just guess it by
checking different numbers right and
additionally we have this uh this
concept of shared governance to to
resolve the original number or the final
answer we're going to need to get all
parties to work together to decrypt it
so let's forward on the the request we
have to to basically multiply by two so
everyone's going to go and do that
operation and they'll keep the result
locally until such time as we're ready
to bring it back together so now we'll
say okay let's bring all our shares
together we agree let's add everything
back and you can see that result 10 is
the same as if we had multiplied the
original five
so if you think about it models and data
sets are just large collections of
numbers which we can encrypt in which we
can compute
if we go back to this problem from
earlier right um how would could it be
possible if i could try to solve this
right without getting on the phone
without doing legal negotiations and
contracts without being able to copy any
data
well why don't we try some remote data
science all right we've got our little
friends
and we'll go to our repository now i
know that this is an r conference and we
are working on different um language
platform uh clients but at the moment is
predominantly python but if you pip
install sift right and then you load up
a jupiter notebook which of course is
where all good data science begins we're
going to jump in here to the first step
so we import sift
the next step is
we're going to go looking for
federated networks of data and we can
use dot networks and this is sort of
like a google search for private data
what we're going to see here is a
collection of different networks that we
can join
so let's go look and drill into the
first one here we'll connect into there
and the next thing we want to do is go
looking at what domains or what websites
of private data are available
so you can see here canada and united
states
perfect that's exactly what i was
looking for so i'm going to jump in i'm
going to get a sort of variable a kind
of handle to connect to these domains
and once i have that the next thing i'm
going to um wonder is like what is my
current privacy budget right now what is
a privacy budget well if you remember
earlier we discussed the idea that with
differential privacy we want to be able
to sort of like you know
tune this this noise and we also want a
self-service model that means that the
data owner doesn't need to be there just
to answer our queries and requests and
approvals and so if we're able to
somehow measure the amount of privacy
that's revealed during a query we could
estimate the amount that protects the
data subjects while also allowing you to
automatically download your results
without anyone being there
so let's have a look we've got 200
privacy budget that's awesome okay let's
keep going
so and now we're going to go try to find
the data set we want to work on so in
this case we have on the left we've got
the canadian domain right and we're
going to go find the data set that
responds to the american data set and we
can see we have some tensors in there
with shapes that's great
and on the other side we're going to go
get the united states domain we're going
to go looking for the data relating to
canada
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try to get two variables that represent
each side now if this was normally in my
local jupyter notebook right these would
be variables that contain the actual
tensors in memory but we don't want that
right we we can't copy the data so
instead what we have is a concept of a
pointer so think of it as like a proxy
object it looks and feels exactly like
the original object in my python
environment except there's no data
inside i can't see it i can't copy
anything
so the simple example here would be like
hey why don't we just subtract one from
the other then we can figure out if
there's a huge difference or not right
that should be easy in theory but i
would need to co-locate the data i would
need to copy it so this shouldn't be
possible i'm here in australia i haven't
made any phone calls or emails right and
the data on the left pointer is all the
way over in america in an encrypted
government uh institution somewhere you
know and the canadian pointer points to
data that's over in canada and a
completely different computer system so
this should not be possible
but it is possible and the way it works
is as soon as i execute this command we
create a shared multi-party compute
tensor and under the hood it points to
the original data and just like you saw
before we're going to pass on this
operation of minus and both sides both
domains are going to communicate to each
other and agree on an encrypted protocol
they will encrypt their data they will
execute the the operation that i've
asked and they'll store the results
locally at this point we've achieved
input privacy no data has left either of
these domains right so we haven't copied
any data but we've still managed to do
encrypted computation
now the next thing is there's no point
running a query if you don't look at the
results right but to make sure that our
data subjects that are that are inside
these data sets are protected we need to
apply some kind of differential privacy
or output privacy and so in this case
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
tell the system hey i would like to look
at this result in a secure way and so
i'm nominating some privacy noise that
i'm willing to sort of add and what's
going to happen is the accountant is
going to look at all the data that i've
used and it's going to think hmm okay
you know this is how much you're using
this is how much privacy it would reveal
this is how much budget you have oh you
have enough that's great okay so we're
just going to subtract it from your
budget and we're going to publish the
results into the domain available for
download
so now at this point i can take that
with a simple dot get
pull back the shares decrypt the result
and now we have it there's a significant
difference between these two things so
that's super awesome
and you know finally i still have a
little bit of privacy budget left over
so you might be wondering like wow this
is like pretty interesting how do i find
out more about this how do i learn about
the technology what it means all this
all this terminology about pets well
we've created three free courses that
you can take to learn all about this the
first one is called our privacy
opportunity and it's tons of awesome
video and quizzes that help you
understand the terminology about pets
and private ai takes you through the
implications for society and governance
and i highly recommend everyone takes is
it's non-technical
and then you know our second course
which came out the start of this year is
uh is called foundations of private
computation this has got a whopping 60
hours of content on federated learning
cryptography homomorphic encryption
secure multi-party compute you name it
it's in there if you take this course
you will know more about this
specialized field than almost anyone
else on the planet and finally we have a
new course that just got released last
week it's called introduction to remote
data science and in this course you're
going to learn how to create your own
domain start it on your laptop or your
own infrastructure you'll learn how to
take your data set and upload it in a
secure way and you'll learn how to do
remote data science between you and your
own domain or another domain and finally
we'll show you how to join a network so
that you can become part of the amazing
discoveries of tomorrow
so there's three courses all free and
available now on courses.openmind.org
go join it today and you'll be one of 8
000 people who have already started
and finally i want to talk a little bit
about what makes open mind unique
so open mind is globally distributed i'm
in australia as far as i know we have
people on every continent except
antarctica
so you know we've got people in brazil
in the united states in canada we have
multiple african nations people all
across europe russia china and lots of
people in india and this is really
important because we believe that we
want to build you know tomorrow's
federated global private data network
and it needs to be accessible to
everyone in the world it needs to be
equal this isn't something we're just
building for silicon valley right and so
it's it's crucial that we take into
account all of the needs and
requirements of everyone in the world
we're also a charity under open
collective which is a registered 501c3
in america and you know essentially what
this means is we can really focus on
that mission and i encourage you to
check it out and possibly contribute
some money um you know another big
really important thing about what we're
doing here is it's all open source we do
all of our development on github uh we
have over 90 repositories full of all
sorts of interesting experimental
encryption and cryptography projects as
well as obviously our big ones like
pipesift and recently you know i did a
check and there's been about 500 unique
contributors to all of our code over the
years um so so come join us you know
open a pull request everyone's welcome
and finally we have a very active slack
community it has over 13 000 members you
can go join it at slack.openmind.org
if you have any questions about this
talk it's a perfect place to go if
you're taking any of the courses you can
get support and help on there i'm theirs
you know so come join the conversation
and finally i just wanted to say you
know the point of this conversation has
been to give you a bit of an
introduction into pets to to help you to
understand that pets aren't just cute
and furry i think they're actually the
future of data science so you know tell
everyone you know about pets and
consider adopting pets in your
organization today
my name is matava you can find me on
this twitter and slack contacts and i
just want to say thank you for your time
and i hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference